people like gary this is all wrong i'm
nice and people walk all over me i'm
like let's break it down becky here's
what's actually happening they're
actually trying to manipulate people you
tried to give somebody some [ __ ] that
they didn't even want because you wanted
something from them garyvee see you're
coming to dallas let me give you a ride
to the hotel to save you some money on
the car translation hey dude i want to
pitch you [ __ ] for 35 minutes while i
get you to the hotel that's not kind
that's manipulation being kind is
predicated on what the other person
wants not what you want to give so when
people say well i'm a nice guy it's just
not true maybe it's not your kindness
it's your inability to have conflict
it's your inability to be candarous that
leads to you getting walked all over but
i believe the walked all over crew was
trying to manipulate an outcome by
giving something they wanted to give not
what the person that they were trying to
get something from wanted i really
believe that